l'idée de faire une préquelle simplement
pour expliquer qu'ils étaient ces
gars-là est d'où il venait
je trouve ça plutôt rigolo après lié
j'avais une condition en fait c'était
qui est pas acquis et pas groulx dedans
c'était juste que les personnages
principaux en fait soit eux et qu'on
s'attache éventuellement à un ou un ou
deux personnages et l'histoire s'est
construite à partir de cette petite
chose la serre d'écrire
d'où venaient les mignons et de dire
comment éventuellement en fait après il
allait rencontrer en fait les différents
méchant de différentes époques et vous
un don pour la méchanceté dans les deux
premiers films les mignons et elles
étaient des faire valoir
à chaque fois qu'on ait besoin d'un
petit moment comique ont coupé sur eux
ont coupé sur un gars qui veut dire une
bêtise qui faisait on a voulu faire un
film en fait qui était un vrai film donc
on s'est dit il faut une bonne histoire
il faut des bons personnages
il faut faire en sorte que si le film se
passe dans les années 60
qu'on ait une bande son mais d'en faire
il faut que même le look du film
d'étalonnage l'aspect du film fasse
d'époque
donc on a décidé de faire un film
alors papa gana tous les pèlerins
connaît pas par ailleurs